Simplify 3 times the
principal root of 500x
to the third power.
So what we're
going to do here is
try to break up this stuff that
we have under the radical sign
into some things that
are perfect squares.
And then we can separately take
the square root of those things
and leave the left overs
inside of the radical sign.
And the other thing
we have to remember
is, principal square
root, this radical sign
here really means the positive
the square root of a number.
So let's think about
this a little bit.
So let's see if
we can break down
the 500x to the third into some
perfect squares and some things
that maybe aren't
perfect squares.
Because 500 is not a perfect
square, and x to the third
is not a perfect square
right from the get go.
So when in doubt, we can just
start to prime factorize this,
and maybe we'll discover
some perfect squares.
So 500 is divisible by
5, and it's 5 times 100.
And you probably
already recognized
that 100 is a perfect square.
It is 10 times 10.
But if you didn't know that,
you could keep factoring it.
You could say, look,
100 is 2 times 50.
50 is 2 times 25,
and 25 is 5 times 5.
So you would see the
perfect squares here,
because you would see two 2's.
So you have a 2 times a 2,
and you have a 5 times a 5.
So you could really just
say that 100 is 10 times 10,
or you could say it's 2
squared times 5 squared.
Either of those
things would allow
you to break this
down a little bit.
And then x to the
third, that's clearly
just the same thing as
x squared times x, which
allows us to break it
down into a perfect square
and something that is
not a perfect square.
So let's just
rewrite these numbers
under the principal root sign.
So this is going to
be equal to 3 times--
and I'll save some
space here-- 3 times.
The 500 I can rewrite
it as 100 times 5,
and 100 I can rewrite
as 10 squared.
So this right here I can
rewrite as 10 squared.
I don't have to do all of
this business down here.
But this will help you recognize
that it's a perfect square.
It's 4 times 25, both of
those are perfect squares.
So that's 10 squared.
So I'm going to write this
as 10 squared times 5.
That's the 500 right over there.
And then I can rewrite the x to
the third as x squared times x.
And then let me extend
my principal root sign
right over here.
And we know from basic
exponent properties,
because that's really
what we're doing here,
taking the square
root of something
is really the same
thing as taking it
to a fractional exponent.
So it's the same
properties that apply.
This is the same thing as
3 times the principal root
of 10 squared times the
principal root-- let
me do it this way-- times
the principal root of 5
times the principal
root of x squared
times the principal root of x.
And now we can
simplify these things.
So the principal
root of 10 squared,
or the principal root of 100,
is going to be positive 10.
Negative 10 is
also equal to 100,
but when you take
the principal root,
you only care about the
positive square root.
So this right over
here is going to be 10.
5 is not a perfect
square, so we'll just
leave this expression
as the square root of 5.
Square root of x squared.
So here you might
be tempted, and I've
seen this done many, many times.
You're tempted to just say,
hey, that's just going to be x.
The square root
of x squared is x.
But what if what
if x is negative?
Let's say that x was negative 2.
Then x squared would be 4.
And the principal root of
4 is equal to positive 2.
It's equal to the
positive square root.
So you can't just say
that this thing over here
is going to be equal to
x, because in this case,
it was equal to the
absolute value of x.
And so that's what we do.
We say that this is equal
to, regardless of whether x
is positive or negative, we
want the positive square root.
So you would say it's equal
to the absolute value of x.
That's what that principal
root does for us.
And so now, if we
simplify it a little bit,
remember with multiplication,
since we're just
multiplying a bunch
of expressions here,
it doesn't matter
what order we do it.
We can switch the order.
So we have all the stuff
out of the radicals
multiplying times
each other first,
and then we have the radicals.
So we have 3 times 10 times
the absolute value of x.
3 times 10 is 30.
So we have 30 times
the absolute value
of x times the square root of
5 times the square root of x.
And you have the principal
or the square root of 5
and the square root of x, you
can actually rewrite this right
here as the square root of 5x.
You're taking the product
of two things that
are raised to the same power.
That's the same thing
as taking the product
and then raising them to
that fractional power.
Or I guess another
way to think of it,
and then taking the square root.
So this all
simplifies to 30 times
the absolute value of x
times the square root of 5x.